[拍手]
マルセルのです
私40年前にこのバルセロナに行きました
あの真のために何かというと
石を掘ります
で15歳ぐらい半世紀ほどに前になりますけれども皆さんと同じように自分はどうやっ
て生きるべきか
そして
人類そんな大学大それたことを当時考えたわけじゃないんですけど
人間って何だろう
自分って何だろうこれは世界中の洋の東西を問わず
世界の若者が一度は疑問に思っ
私も同じようにその2問に答えるべく
努力したんですが
その一番良い方法は何かと感じたのが
石を掘ることじゃないか
ちょっとこれはの
論理的じゃないんですね
直感です
ただ
人類の一番古いお仕事って言いますか
石を彫って過ごしてきた石器時代という
その意志を掘ることにがとても大事な時代があったそれが今それが薄れてきてでも意志
を掘る人は
まあ社会の停電
歩いているような感じですが一度こりますとこれ
離れられないみなさんもぜひおすすめします
その意志をホールビズ6
それが身体の中を持って言えば宇宙のリズムと何かこうあっているような心地よいいい
気分になるんですね
でっ
でもそれは石を彫っているとうまく掘れない場合手を打ちます
血を流します当然汗を流します
ですがその
人間のに津波の
最低限のことを続けることによって
何か自分の生きる道が水変わるんじゃないかということで
じゃあ石を掘るんだったら石の文化のたくさんあるヨーロッパに行けばいいじゃないと
いうことを言っよっています
う
日本とドイツラインに世界頂山の
経験した方は私を含めていらっしゃらないと思いますがありまして二つの国がもう
ゴロゴロになりました
日本は全く新しい街が出来ました
ドイツはその
破壊された年を次の日から壊れた石に番号
いつかは元に戻そうということで作り始めました
再建されましたアドレスでなんてまったくもう廃墟だったのが今戦争もなかったかの
ようになっています
ドイツに行けば良い歯が折れるんじゃないかと思って私はヨーロッパに渡ったんですが
同一の人手刀たちは体を聞い c
彼らと戦うにはちょっと栄養をつけなきゃなと思いまして
そこが私のちょっと弱いところなのか
今の強いところなのか
栄養のあるスペインに来
あそこで波紋とワイン西ノ宮
ドイツ人戦いんじゃないかと
ところが
スペインに行きますとこの
サクラダファミリアがありましたおいしじゃないか
昆明でキャラってのはですよ
がれきの石が山ほど積んだよここは何してるのかな
解体しているのかな何か何をしてもあんまり音もしないし
でもよく見ると石の原石はんです
医師の原石があるというのは何かを作ろうとしてるんです
古いものばかりだったらも借りたしている
原石はこの中のこんなデカイのじゃなくてもいいから
きちゃないかけらでいいからほらしてほしい
そうすればヨーロッパに来た甲斐が少しはあると思いまして
掛け合いましたところが全くスペイン語がわからない
ん
ですが自分の作った写真石を彫った写真を見せました
でもそこまでに至るまで2カ月以上
誰が責任者なのかもわからない誰に聞いても分から全く無名です
今でこそ世界中の人が毎日何万人も訪れるところですが当時全くの運営の赤化世界でし
たでまぁ責任者をやっと見つけて見せましたらあそうか試験をするっていうので
果物組と葉っぱのついた枝を渡されて
これ
僕は彫刻家だからあの
石を掘りただけなんだけどじゃあこれを形にすればいいんだな
これあの
レストランだったらこれをどうやって料理したがいいのかなと考えるでしょうか
やっぱりこういうところですから彫刻にしようということでそれを彫刻にしました幸い
それを
認められて仕事がになりましたん
その時に作ったものを10年後に入っ
くっています
で
ここで仕事が始まったんですが
40年経ってますから城一例は僕を待ってないと思うんですけど
このセーターのも
ここがユネスコローリーという人は1人で7つも8つもユネスコの世界遺産持っている
人です
このように
本堂が出来上がっていますん
ところが私が言った通りこのころです
レーザーってあるんですか
ません
見えますかねこの指の
ウリの方メイクと頭に白いたいグルを巻いた男が立っているの
これです
60m の手すりもハシゴも何もないところ
まぁ今度オリンピックあります鉄棒選手のにポット
これらの今日であるんですね走行
懸垂して登って
で足をかけたその立ち上がる瞬間に上野て像を持つんですね
それをしないと家ますあれ
で60メートルを登って
図ったり色々しながらあの
手伝ってくれているか量も鉄棒に行こうしゃがみ込んでますけれども
そういう仕事をしてました
35年間は私非正規社員です
で作っていた学校です
高さ5メートル延べ20メートルの石で作った
ベランダ彫刻
これが最初の私の仕事をよく任せますね
言葉も分からない外国人に最初のでもこれ大切なのはガウディの部分と新しい部分を
つなげる大事なところだったんですねちょうど
飛んでき見るなんと影
こういう危ないって言いますが大きな仕事を任せてみようと
でやり遂げましたが2つ問題がありました
下から計算していくとこれ自分で図面も引かなきゃいけないんですがこの三角形のい
ないものが最後は1センチん通してもらう
1センチの厚みの黄道帯石を通してガウリイは
作ろうとしたのかそれが一つの疑問
もう一つは彫刻をおけということ葉っぱ
彫刻を受けという時にどうのようにして構成していったらいいのか
ガウディがあったらどうするだろうと
考えるわけですがそれはデザインのもう一つ紋
この2つの問題を
どうして解決したんか私ずっとなりましたが
だいたいアルキメデスのようにお風呂で大た気がつくんですけれども
ふと気づいたのこの構造の問題弱いという問題と彫刻を置くところは一つじゃないか
つまり弱いと思っているところに貼っパーおけば強い
くなる構造的に
デホ少ない材料で使い堀ができる
これは本当の合理性です
私そこで初めてガウリイと出会いました
ラウディという人は
二つの問題を一つの答えで解決するんだ
いやもしかしたら3つの問題を一つの答えで解決しようとしたんじゃない
つまり構造の問題
構造は彫刻のためにあるのではない彫刻があるから構造が持つんです
我々人生でたくさんの問題であります
それを我々は分けて考えすぎてないでしょうか
皆さん真面目な
方々ん
問題を解決しよう2のその問題を開きます
開いたら何科でしょう
今まで知らなかったまたいくつかの問題が出てくる
真面目な日本人はそれをまた割ってみると
また次の問題で
問題の方がどんどんどんどん自分をかけてくる
どうやって解決したらいいんですよ毎日毎日がどんどんどんどん問題が増えていくわけ
皆さんそういう顔してますよね
その問題を解決する方法それが私が最初に出会った買う
いくつもの問題を解決できるひとつの答えを探すこと
ちょっと待ってくださいこれ難しいと思うでしょうが
今3000年機を生きようとしてます我々はこれから専念
18年経ってますけれども
人類はどのようにして生きていこうとしているのか
世界中の人間がこれから1000年人類は無事に生きていけるかどうか不安に思ってい
ます
そのヒントがそこにある
我々の目はローブ常遠くが見えませんトークの臭いもかけません
ライオンやショーのようにた速く走れない
この影られたこの肉体で何をすればいいのか
大事なことが
総合的にみること
それともう一つあとで申し上げる
みなさんここでお話しされた方々皆に言葉には使わずいっておられること
人のために役に立つこと
人を幸せにすること
皆さんの東京はそこにあるでもそれは愛情があるから
愛情
で
ここで最初のガウリイがでと出会いこのようにフルーツもたくさんつくりました
3m の15トンのベネチアングラスで作りました
なぜフルーツがあるのかがおり前にティックル果物が食べろと言っています
でもここまでする必要はないだろう
大窓45m 全部フルーツですで
まあ皆明年くるかもしれませんがこの一つ一つが1本の意思で
フルーツと葉っぱが一緒になっています
これ1トンの石をですね御影石を5日でホルンです
5日で貼らないと仕事が
取得しちゃいますか
それを200個
200種
おかげさまで良いカンタンになりましたん
これが最初の試験の
葉っぱと振るう
こういったものを10年前から考えながら作ってるんですけれども
この意味を誰も分からない
ガーリーの弟子の方が生きておられましたから誰もわかんないです
でもでも意味が分からなければ彫刻できないんですよ
で私考えましたガウディフルーツ好きだろうけどこれもっと深い意味柄
教会というのは教会です
ミサでお話をしながらことばによって人々の魂を清めそして満たす成長させるそれが
協会の大きな仕事言葉
4判でも言葉雪と言っています
この言葉というの日本人皆さんはも耳にします
涌波と書きます
こんな言葉を世界中にないんです
我々は自然から学んだ知恵で文化を育んできました
私が今こう喋っているのは目に見えない
葉っぱなんです
この葉っぱがもし去年の葉っぱとか人から聞いた葉っぱとか言葉とか拾ってきたことが
ではなく自分の中から本当にエネルギーを込めて皆さんにお伝えしたとしたらもしかし
たら皆さんがそのエネルギーを受け止めて皆さんの魂
豊かな方も
生まれたばかりの新鮮な青い魂の方も
実っていくかもしれん
それがここの仕事運
さくらファミだというのはゲイ作品ではない
私たちの魂が
ミドルための道具なんです
その像号私たちは作って
さていっ
いろんな店主も作らせてもらいました
門扉を作らせてもらいました
ここでクローバーレスすれば40年かかりますから15分
これも作りこのせたのもなぜガウリイはこれを作ろうとしたのか
これ実は
俺が俺がね楽器ピアノなんです
100m のグランドピアノ
人類史上誰も考えなかった
100m のグランドピアノですよそれがをその音が水平に待ち中に流れるように
パイプ状の叩いて鳴らすと音が
県からではなくて宣伝流れていきますから
地上に響きます
この聖堂の中に2000人のコーラス隊の席マン
半耐寒は100メートルのオルガンです一つの楽器です
つまり人を喜ばせる旅の楽器
魂を見とあの実らせるための道具を我々は作ってるん
でもなんでこんなに傾いた柱とか
おかしな構造ばっかこれもう一つの教会ですなぜこんな危ない柱を立てるんでしょう
人に緊張感を与えるためでしょうか
そうじゃない
ラブリーがやろうとしたのは実は
彼を神の言葉にこういうのがあります
人は想像しない
発見するだけだ
しかもその3台な本の名前は自然
という本
人間できること先ほど申し上げた我々が掲げる限りあるこの肉体にどのようにして我々
は生き延びていかなきゃいけないのか
それは
卑屈の問題を解決する一つの答えをさがその方法は
自然を開削観察することここにもし会社の社長さんがおられて
若いクリエイティブの若者をお探しだったら諦めてください
人間にはそれはクリエイティブなものができない
人間できること観察と発見です
その観察して発見するためには先ほど申し上げた愛情
人を幸せにしたいだからこれはやこの人に役に立つんじゃないかと思うのはそこに愛情
がある
でなぜこんな傾いた柱があるのか
これはその実験ですけれども
構造というのは引力に逆らって立てるものです
それを何千年何千年の間
建築家やってきました鉄筋コンクリートがこういう空間をつくることでもこれは引力今
も闘ってるんです
24時間戦い続けてい
陰力というのは本当に無限の力がいい
それと戦い続けて勝てるでしょうか
私はここで申し上げたいのはガウリイ後ほんと後本当の合理性等何なのか
このサグラダファミリアの本堂の行動隊で引力に逆らってただ意図でつり下げられた
わけです
これ揺らせば揺れますけれども必ず元にもでも一つの答えは1つ自然は裏切らない
その裏切らない答えをなぜ利用できないんでしょ
これをひっくり返すことによって先ほどの
正本堂の柱が全部建てられています
ですからどの柱も垂直の柱1本もない
微妙に傾いています
それは引力に逆らってないからです
これは先ほどの頭の逆さまです
懸垂曲線 in 濁に逆らわないか等を
石で積んでいけば今度は引力が
助けてくれる
淫熟という力猛炎の力がそれが24時間働いて支えてくれているんですよ
お金払ってるん
税金も付加価値税もない
ありがたいことだ
ガウディの知恵というのは
昨日まで最大の敵であったその陰力を最大の味方にした
人間できることはそこなんん
敵だと思っている限りそれはずっと的です
その適用5日は味方にするその知恵が人間には可能性として秘められているんだという
こと
ガウディが証明してくれています
こんな厄介な柱でも
すべてが
関数計算とかいろんなものを使えばきれないんですけれども
腕の良い職人が数学も知らない職人が数と石膏の型をねじりながら
しかも軸はとありますからタバコ吸いながら予想向いていてもできるんですけどね
これを繰り返すことによってただこういう複雑な死者が出てくるようにが飽きが来ませ
ん
まぁ話はないので
これはちょっと行きますか
批判そうな
自然にすべての答えがある
だからこの本美しいんですっ
本当の合理性だから美しいん奇をてらって作ったものではない
じゃあ建物には窓が必要ですここには窓はありませんけれども
窓は何のために必要か
ここには光を必要としないか光のためです
課税雨のためだったら壁ていい
じゃあ光のために窓を作るのであれば
答えは光が知ってる
行動は引力が答えを出したデザイン
窓は光がで座にすべきだ
光を一点に集めまして東から昇って西に大でいる間に
すずみのような
一箇所に集中形ができるんですね
それで窓を作りますと思いのほか構造的に強いものになる
窓を穴を開けるって言う枠構造体をしてしまうものですから
ところはこの方法を使うと構造体が弱くならない
で性弾性堂の屋根の上はこのように明かり取りがそのような形でたくさん空いています
では今度煙突もう一つのが文作
傘ミラー
集団
住宅です集合住宅
その煙突喚起のための円と2をなぜこんな
速読ソフトクリームみたいな形にするのか
煙突は何のためにあるのか煙突のデザインを誰に頼むのか
誰でしょう
空気
風です
右から山から一日中風が吹いている
あるセンターの屋上建物の屋上に
まあ風を巻き込む形を模し作ることが知ってきたらそのスピードを上げさせることが
できたら
気圧を変えて中の煙を吸いだせるんじゃないか
ガウディの試みです
飛行機が問う前
こういう飛んでたんでしょうね
でも飛行機が飛ぶのは気圧を変えることによって羽で吸い上げる
別に課税を下から受けて飛んでるわけじゃないんです
そういった自然の力をフルに使うこと
自然というのは我々に与えられた
陰力も冊もすべて我々がどのように使うかによってそれは的になるのか見方になるのか
おお違う
ガウリイの本当の合理性
ガウリイが心心の中に持っていた子供のような思い
人を幸せにしたり自分を幸せにしたいそのためには人を幸せにするしかない
それが一番の自分の幸せなんだということを知っていた誰もしていたがある日は
なんとかその答えを見つけた方それは与えられたものをフルに使うこと
我々が今使っている本合理性という言葉
何かで少し間違ってないだろう
エコロジーという言葉少し弱すぎないんだ
自然というユダイナ力をもっともっとフルにダイナミックに使う
それがガウディの本当の猫レジでやり本当の合理性です
そしてガウディはポケットマネーで相良妙に学校立てました
何が大切か
これからの子どもたちが
どのような教育を受けるかそれによって次の世代が変わります
てして皆さんが手遅れというわけじゃない
ここで申し上げたいの子供たちのを受けるこの学校で
まずですね135年作り続けて死亡事故ないんですよさがハメ
奇跡だね愛妻同じなおしまいですね
私はその理由を考えまして私はこの学校だと思います
この学校というのは
ポケットマネーでが売りがどうしても作らなきゃいけなかった
それは職人たちは子どもを連れて桜が磨きます当時本当に街ではなかったので
子供ずそうすると無意識のうちに子どもを連れて帰らなきゃいけないんですね
喧嘩しないんです紹介等
まして子どもになおは座の顔見世られません
子供を
今勉強してるんだと自分が汗畑
流して働いているけど子供もしかしたら自分用にもいい正規生活ができるようになるか
もしれない教育を受けているんだ
と思うと職人たちは希望です
大人にとっての本当の規模
はた皆さんは給料をもらって生活してます
それも希望ですですが毎年救助一緒だったら希望ないですよね
でも会社としては給料を10%ずつを上げるわけにもいかない
本当の報酬は何でしょう
希望です
そして教育です
自分の子供が良い教育を送って自分用にも良い生活ができる
そのためだったら親は何でもします
本当の皆さん社長様になる
社員の方に一号という
給料を与えられる人がもらえたらその会社
うんますで学校をつくった
食みたい安い給料や樽職人たちでの対処が本当の報酬
希望です
でここでを支えていたこと
おとなしく子供達本当はしたいんでしょうけれども泥遊びを一人にさせてここでチリッ
と物理とそして科学
水と土と石
その関係その関係を知った上でチリがどうなっているかもしれん
今チリも物理も科学もはかけて教えてるでしょ
子供は分けては分からないです
一緒に知りたいんですこの世界は何なのか
これが本当のそう教育ではないでしょうか
100年前に行われた驚異
今それをしなきゃいけない
私が最初に申し上げた構造等
昨日と象徴そういったものを別々のものを一つの答えで見つけることそれはなかなか
難しい
でも今
この子どもたちに
本当の理由られてない教育をしていけば
一つの
答えによっていくつかの問題を解決しようとする気持ちが芽生えるんじゃないか
ここでは子どもたちがお遊戯してますですが持っているものは繁栄とか曲線的
まグラフとかそういっただき科学数学と音楽一緒の人昔じゃないか
幾何学と数学を言っ就農支援でもオリジンは一緒です
音楽からピタゴラスは通学を発見した
子供たちにはそれが一番理解しやすい
1本も日本を進めることができる
この学校
ガウリイは安い材料で
薄い壁を縦に立てて作りました
神のような壁です
髪を立たないでしょう
本当の氷精というのは
ある文を絶たないからそれは使えないというのが合理性ではなく本来あるべきものない
方法を探しだそうじゃないか
それが合理性でず
髪を縦にはどうしたらいい
皆さん
最後の登板者に少し元気だし朝してください
髪を解いたというみなさん答え知ってますよ
そうです屏風です
で雨水油水レンガという安いもので薄い壁でパってるんですよ
しかも
これを伸ばしますとハート型になります
こちらを伸ばしますともう一つハート型
真ん中にももう一つハート型があって3つのハートでこの今日学校当たってるん
希望と構造と象徴その3つを一つの答えでい
を見つける
ガーリーは
生涯僚機でした小児リュウマチまま生涯を過ごしました
だから1日7010キロ
あること74歳まで敷いていいっ
自然に魅かれるまで
彼はちょっと頑固なところがあって道は人間のためにあるんだろう
にも左も見る必要はない真っ直ぐ歩けと言って自然に惹かれちゃう
ちょっと右と左をみたほうがいいですうん
でもガウディが本当に求めたもの
この x マチでまっすぐ眠れないそのからだいたい体を
ソファのようなベッドで眠るとき
夢を見ました
将来のこの桜が花 media どのようになる
そしてこのさからハミを見て人々はどのように
発見するだろうそしてどのように幸せな世界をつくってくれるだろう
彼の本当の美名
人類が
ずっと幸せに生き続けること
その夢を見ることによって彼は安らかな
m-でしょう
夢を見ましょうそして本当の合理性を探しましょう
この3000年金を生きるためにはガウリイがたくさんヒントを残しています
ぜひ信じて
違う世界をそしてこの
てペレックス使ってみんな夢中を集め
このガウディと同じように
人を幸せにするため
ていきましょう
今日はどうもありがとう
[拍手]
[音楽]